eine gigantische explosion eines
asteroiden könnte möglicherweise die
beiden sünden städte sodom und gomorrha
zerstört haben bis zu 40.000 menschen
könnten auf einen schlag getötet worden
sein und das war historisch gesehen erst
vor kurzer zeit wieder ein beleg für die
ständige bedrohung durch asteroiden bei
ausgaben wurden jetzt spuren einer
bisher verborgenen katastrophe
apokalyptischen ausmaßes gefunden klicks
um science im future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts wissen
herzlich willkommen
es muss ein außergewöhnlich dramatisches
ereignis vor 3600 jahren in der nähe von
calais hamam gewesen sein möglicherweise
vergleichbar mit dem tunguska ereignis
im jahr 1908 eine furchteinflößende
erscheinung in zentralasien und sibirien
als damals eine feuerkugel knallend und
knatternd über den wolkenlosen himmel
raste und dabei ihre bahn über hunderte
von kilometern zog in einem gebiet über
der tiger spaltete ein blitz den himmel
und feuersäulen stiegen auf eine
hitzewelle rollte über die region
menschen wurden durch die luft
geschleudert und 80 millionen bäume
entwurzelt zahlreiche tiere verbrennen
in den wäldern ein großes rätsel denn
noch immer ist nicht klar was damals
wirklich geschehen ist fakt ist es war
eine gewaltige explosion
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben in computersimulationen die
wirkung herausgefunden dass es sich
dabei etwa um die tausendfache
sprengkraft der hiroshima bombe
gehandelt haben muss mit an sicherheit
grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit ist ein
asteroid in einer höhe von etwa acht
kilometern auseinander gebrochen wurden
auf ähnliche art und weise auch die
beiden sünden städte sodom und gomorrha
dem erdboden gleichgemacht ein us
forschungsteam hat sich mit dem
mysteriösen rätsel um diese beiden
biblischen städte beschäftigt dazu sagt
einer der beteiligten wissenschaftler
james
es gibt hinweise auf einen großen
kosmischen feuer war in der nähe von
calais hammer möglicherweise gab es hier
sogar einen aufprall der vergleichbar
mit dem sein könnte der vor langer zeit
zum aussterben der dinosaurier führte
eben nur in kleinerem maßstab das os
forschungsteam hat über jahre hinweg
ausgrabung in thalham durchgeführt dabei
handelt es sich um ein gebiet in
jordanien und zwar um den östlichen teil
des unteren jordan tals nahe der mündung
des jordan fachleute weltweit gehen
davon aus dass sich hier damals die
biblische stadt sodom befunden haben
muss sodom und gomorrha sind laut der
bibel durch gott ausgelöscht worden
indem er schwefel und feuer auf die
stadt herab regnen ließ der grund die
sünde ihrer bewohnerinnen und bewohner
im alten testament heißt es so viel wie
als die sonne über dem land aufgegangen
und load ins heim gekommen war ließ der
herr auf sodom und gomorrha schwefel
feuer regnen er ließ ihre städte
einstürzen mitsamt ihrem ganzen umkreis
auch alle einwohner der städte und alles
was auf den feldern wuchs
wissenschaftlich ist noch nicht
endgültig bewiesen ob es die beiden
städte wirklich gegeben hat und falls ja
wo sie dann genau sagen möglicherweise
handelt es sich um die gegend rund um
das tote meer in israel für den us
forscher stephen collins ist thalhammer
der beste kandidat für die verschollene
berühmt berüchtigte stadt sodom die nach
biblische erzählung von gott in einer
feurigen katastrophe für ihre sünden und
frevel tat und zerstört wurde jetzt hat
sich ein forschungsteam noch einmal
genauer mit dem thema beschäftigt und
dazu faszinierende ergebnisse
vorgestellt was konnten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
durch die mehrjährigen ausgrabungen
offenbar vor 3600 jahren war die
stadtteil el hammam die wohl größte
stadt am östlichen mittelmeer ungefähr
zehn mal größer als das damalige
jerusalem in der vergangenheit hatten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
vermehrt hinweise darauf gefunden dass
diese stadt die quelle für die
biblischen erzählung um die zerstörung
der städte sodom und gomorrha ist dazu
sagt der us forscher james kennen
es handelt sich um eine unglaublich
kulturell wichtige gegend ein großteil
der entwicklung der frühen kulturellen
komplexität des menschen hat ihren
ursprung in dieser region bereits vor
zwei jahren hatte ein us forschungsteam
anzeichen dafür aufgespürt dass ein
asteroid vor etwa 3600 jahren in der
luft explodiert sein könnte die gesamte
zivilisation in dieser gegend zeit
dadurch vernichtet worden damals hatten
die fachleute die bodenbeschaffenheit
überprüft und bodenproben unterhalb und
oberhalb der asche schichten
geochemische analysiert demnach habe
sich die bodenbeschaffenheit durch ein
ereignis in dieser region verändert
sowohl in der bibel als auch in
historischen berichten sei sie immer als
landwirtschaftlich reich beschrieben
worden plötzlich aber wurde das gebiet
etwa 700 jahre lang nicht mehr bewohnt
die analyse der bodenproben zeigte das
unter- und oberhalb der asche schichten
der drei- bis vierfache salzgehalt
enthalten war das wachstum von gerste
und weizen ist da nicht möglich den
fachleuten zufolge könnte es eine
riesige schockwellen der explosion
gewesen sein die eine schicht aus salz
aus dem toten meer über die gesamte
region verteilt hatte somit war das land
jahrhundertelang land wirtschaftlich
gesehen nutzlos auf den ehemals
fruchtbaren boden konnte nichts mehr
wachsen und die menschen waren für
jahrhunderte gezwungen das gebiet zu
verlassen
eine analyse der mauer anlage offenbarte
den fachleuten damals dass es
möglicherweise eine enorm starke
stoßwelle gegeben haben muss eine fläche
von 500 quadratkilometern könnte dadurch
zerstört worden sein durch die stadt
selbst ein feuer gewütet was die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus einer dicken ascheschicht schließen
der das gelände bedeckt die aktuelle
studie kommt zu ähnlichen ergebnissen
der einschlag des asteroiden könnte
demnach also die komplette stadtteil el
hammam zerstört haben und somit die
vorlage für die geschichte in der bibel
gewesen sein das forschungsteam schreibt
dazu die angenommene energie war größer
als die explosion über tunguska in
russland im jahr 1908 wo ein meteorit
von 50 metern größe auseinanderfiel das
allein war 1000 mal mehr energie als bei
der atombombe über hiroshima freigesetzt
wurde als meteoriten werden generell
asteroiden und meteoriten bezeichnet die
oder deren teile die erdoberfläche
erreichen die ausgrabung legen nahe dass
die gebäude durch eine explosion
zerstört worden seien die reste der
mächtigen stadtmauer enthalten demnach
unter anderem geschmolzen quartz
geschmolzene ton gegenstände diamant
artigen kohlenstoff kügelchen aus
geschmolzenem kalk sowie platin iridium
nickel gold und silber doch solche
materialien schmelzen erst ab einer
temperatur von mehr als 2000 grad
celsius auch die bodenanalysen liefern
nach angaben des forschungsteams
hinweise für eine solche explosion am
himmel beispielsweise wurden
geschmolzene metalle aufgespürt dazu
heißt es in der aktuellen studie von
jobs kennt und seinem team die
wichtigste entdeckung besteht meiner
meinung nach aber in der entdeckung von
quarz der einen gewaltigen druck
ausgesetzt gewesen sein musste auch
diese funde sprechen für eine schwere
explosion am himmel über thalhammer die
explosion könnte sich demnach etwa in
vier kilometern höhe ereignet haben die
stoßwelle die sich daraus ergab hat
nicht nur alle gebäude dem erdboden
gleich gemacht sondern auch die etwa
8000 einwohnerinnen und einwohner
getötet andere fachleute gehen sogar
davon aus dass bis zu 40.000 menschen
von dieser gigantischen katastrophe
betroffen waren die us
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
spürten baustoffe auf die zu glas
eingeschmolzen waren und lehmziegel mit
hitze blasen auch diese funde deuten die
fachleute als hinweise darauf dass es
während des katastrophen ereignisses zu
ungewöhnlich hohen temperaturen gekommen
sein muss doch klar ist zu dieser zeit
damals gab es keine technologie die
einen solchen schaden hätten anrichten
können demnach zeigen die ausgrabung
dass es tatsächlich viele
übereinstimmung mit der erzählung aus
der bibel gibt feuer im himmel es
regnete steine und dichter rauch
umhüllte die stadt die gesamte stadt
wurde zerstört alle bewohnerinnen und
bewohner vielen dem tragischen ereignis
zum opfer dazu sagt archäologe james
kennen
die biblische erzählung klingt
tatsächlich wie ein augenzeugenbericht
eines kosmischen einschlags alle
schilderungen in der genesis stimmen mit
einer kosmischen luft detonation überein
aber natürlich gibt es keinen
wissenschaftlichen beweis dass es sich
bei thalia hammer um das so dumm des
alten testaments handelt dennoch könnte
die damalige katastrophe die grundlage
jeder erzählung gebildet haben die sich
bis heute in der niederschrift der
biblischen genesis über die zerstörung
von sodom und gomorrha aber auch des
biblischen jerichos erhalten hat und das
zeigt mal wieder wie oft es zu ihnen die
erde bedrohen aber die forschung kommt
da ja inzwischen immer besser voran wir
schicken inzwischen sondern zu
asteroiden zum ersten mal astrid
bombardiert rio plata liefert
spektakuläre erkenntnisse extrem
spannendes video also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren das geht mit
dem abo button unter jedem video kostet
nichts und macht schlauch bis dann bleib
dran